prosecutors are revealing disturbing new
details about years of alleged abuse
suffered by the 13 siblings found
captive in Southern California
it's their parents David and Louise
Turpin who pleaded not guilty yesterday
the couple could face life in prison
David Beck knows outside their home in
Paris that's southeast of Los Angeles
where people are leaving cards and gifts
David good morning Gail good morning
bail for the parents has been set at 12
million dollars each look the alleged
abuse here has been going on for years
according to prosecutors dating back to
when the family was living in Texas the
plan to escape was planned about two
years ago prosecutors say one of the 17
year old girls snuck out of one of these
windows on Sunday morning and she took
another sibling with her but the other
sibling got scared and went back inside
but that didn't derailed plan David and
Louise Turpin appeared before a judge
Thursday David and Chains both are
charged with committing years of torture
against their own children
he's accused of committing a lewd act
against a minor this is severe emotional
physical abuse this is depraved conduct
prosecutors say in addition to the
beatings the children were also
restrained with ropes these defendants
eventually began using chains and
padlocks to chain up the victims to
their beds these punishments would last
for weeks or even months at a time they
alleged the children were not allowed to
use the bathroom take more than one
shower a year or wash their hands above
the wrists they were fed very little on
a strict schedule
leaving them severely malnourished the
29 year old a female victim weighs 82
pounds the parents are also accused of
taunting them they would buy food
including pies leave it on the counter
let the children look at it but not eat
the food the 13 siblings have not been
to a doctor in years and they've never
seen a dentist they are still
hospitalized undergoing physical and
mental evaluations that will take at
least two weeks
workers say their adjustments to society
will be challenging with some of the
children even unaware of what medicine
is they like a basic knowledge of life
many of the children didn't know what a
police officer was
the DEA was asked if religion has
anything to do with this was it in any
way involved and he said not that I know
of now I can tell you there were journal
entries that investigators found inside
the house and those apparently will be
crucial in this case John interestingly
the family and the parents were awake
all night and apparently slept all day
and apparently the malnutrition was so
bad that the muscles on the kids were
wasting away David thanks inhuman